la semaine dernière se tenait à lyon en
france le 10e forum mondial biovision
sur l'avenir des systèmes de santé
le forum de cette année portait sur la
médecine personnalisée et regrouper des
centaines de médecins de chercheurs de
représentants des pharmaceutiques ainsi
que des gouvernements et notre
chroniqueur à la santé michel rochon il
était lui aussi à titre d'animateur
michel bonsoir bonsoir seville a d'abord
dit nous ce qu'est cette médecine
personnalisée qui est à nos portes
et pourtant on sait assez peu de choses
là dessus oui effectivement il est
délégué à lyon sont conscients que
public n'est pas au courant si
véritablement basé sur la génétique et
la génomique
on regroupe sa part un espèce de de
phrase magique les quatre replis alors
regardons ensemble ce que soient les cas
groupés
oui donc une médecine préventive
prédictive personnalisé et participative
en prévention on en parle beaucoup mais
là c'est une prévention vraiment ciblé
sur votre profil génétique et quand on
parle de prédictive vin c'est l'arrivée
de tous ces nouveaux tests qui vont
permettre de savoir d'avancé vos
prédispositions à certaines maladies
dont le cancer par exemple personnalisé
baisser le traitement alors on aura
développé des nouvelles molécules des
nouveaux médicaments ciblés sur votre
profil génétique fini le fameux
médicament un médicament pour tous très
ciblées pour vous et participative c'est
de perdre vous permettre de suivre votre
maladie donc par internet par des
applications vous allez pouvoir rentrer
vos données et suivre l'évolution de
votre maladie en temps réel tout ça
c'est une révolution qui est à nos
portes
donc c'est très prometteur en même temps
on sait dans quel état et notre système
de santé est ce qu'on va avoir les
moyens d'en arriver à ce genre de
médecine lunch est effectivement c'est
une médecine qui sera très exigeante sur
le système on voit toutes sortes de
problèmes à paraître regardons ensemble
il y en a de nombreux alors problèmes
éthiques financiers structurels
commençons par et si vous voulez alors
si je prends votre adn et je sais
exactement l'ensemble des maladies il y
avait là une question de droit
fondamental à la vie privée il ya des
questions éthiques et de droit qui sont
liées à sa qui n'ont pas encore été
véritablement adressé par exemple notre
employeur voilà votre compagnie
d'assurance et caetera et il a il ya
toute la question de peut-on accélérer
la roche
georges pour sortir ses militants alors
rapidement tant que des problèmes
structurels des problèmes d'argent
la solution c'est le partenariat public
privé soit l'ont évidemment on pense à
une médecine pour les pays riches
oui déjà on n'a peut-être pas les moyens
d'en arriver là si vite que ça alors les
pays pauvres comment est ce qu'ils vont
faire pour amorcer ce genre de virage
je crois qu'ils auront beaucoup de
difficultés là on nous avait des
démonstrations d'applications qui permet
de contrôler le diabète en afrique
mais si pilon pas besoin de cela pour
l'instant ils ont besoin d'hôpitaux
alors oui ça c'est un grave problème les
pays du tiers-monde et donc vous qu'est
ce que vous retenez de ce sommet michel
ben je retiens acharnement de la part
des scientifiques et des pharmas d'aller
de l'avant
mais selon moi ça va se faire très
lentement dans dix quinze ans on aura
commencé à en parler ici merci beaucoup
michel merci beaucoup au feeling